I have, uh,
I have a lot of gay friends.
I like my gay friends
'cause I don’t think
there’s like a more honest
relationship between, like,
a gay dude and a straight dude,
'cause there’s just like nothing
to gain, you know,
so it’s just pure honesty.
But there’s always one gay friend
that I don’t think
is fucking gay at all.
Girls laugh.
Every guy's like, "Yeah, Kyle."
It’s that gay dude that’ll like,
run up on your girlfriend,
and like squeeze her boobs,
and like slap her ass,
and be like,
"Damn girl, you look great!"
I don’t find that fucking funny
like at all, I’m sorry.
Like, I’m all for the gayness,
you know.
It doesn’t mean
I’m against gayness.
It’s just like you just get to
slap ass on a technicality?
That’s not fucking fair at all.
Right in front of you.
Walk up, slap the ass, giggle.
You know?
Just 'cause he could.
I would never do that
just 'cause I could, you know?
I wouldn’t like walk up
to his boyfriend
and like tug his dick
and be like,
“Nice, Gary!
Not for me, but cool!”